dès que j'ai l'impression que monsieur
pascal praud et intervenir c'est pour
nous parler peut-être de la victoire des
nantais
[Rires]
sen avait dit
le petit
n'a ni queue ni
visiter son village il les tient je sors
une petite question sur nino
les plaies sont encore à vif émoi mais
musée du sel le sujet de l'année
[Musique]
deux semaines après avoir acheté twitter
l'homme le plus riche du monde s'est vu
pousser des ailes
et c'est peu dire le milliardaire qui
devait se rendre de sun rosé à san
francisco a préféré troquer sa tesla
électrique contre son jet privé à très
écolo tout ça surtout quand on sait que
les deux villes sont à 77 km l'une de
l'autre fois 50 minutes en voiture ou
approximativement un baril clermont la
durée totale du trajet 9 minutes et une
poignée de secondes qui fait quoi dans
les a je travaille on a fait de l'ancien
sur l'île tu sais de cash ma timidité je
me tiens allez et je lâche toile tout ce
qui est logistique e services de
sécurité hôtesses ailleurs pourrait
travailler pour à nouveau est habillé
comme les hôtesses
moi ça c'est pas très gentil de ça
vous avez quel âge
[Applaudissements]
pour mickaël c'est la goutte d'eau le
gendarme met les points sur les i par
contre a arrêté de me dire que j'ai des
questions bêtes ont suggéré de me dire
que j'ai des questions mais je vais vous
embarquez pour outrage et ça vous faire
tout drôle ce que j'ai dit christian
gates mais je vous sais pas si c'est pas
vous dit j'ai quelques questions sont
bêtes ou pas bête paraît que vous avez
déjà pris un jet vous pour 12 minutes
pour aller à bruxelles où ça pour aller
à bruxelles sa bruxelles - la belgique
quoi doper
des rythmes et c'est que rien je pense
que ça devait cazouls d'hérault un
aller-retour france quinze mille euros
aller retour ouais vous étiez prêts si
vous deviez être jamais jamais un dîner
et en fait j'ai fait le dîner je suis
reparti
bien sûr j'avais qu'est l'os s'il vous
plaît et ben voilà c'est simple en plus
on y arrive pourquoi faire le barbeau
arrêté lever les yeux au ciel
ce qu'on appellera le proc et qu'on
dirait que le team 7 23 ans qui roulait
que la voiture de papa c'était contrôlé
et qu'il en garde à vue pour outrage il
habite redescendre monsieur ban trois
ans dans la porsche de papa ok c'est
vrai que ça fait douze minutes 2 metal
et au dîner installée petit dîner je
crois que c'était un dîner si c'est pas
si tu fais ça tu pas ça pour une meuf
impressionné les centrales et oui
c'était pour un modèle c'était pour
aller voir une femme crois tu te prends
mais tu avais ce nom ah bon
[Musique]
des shows temps déjà je prends
maintenant je
rigole stokes directeur à la des
plateformes donc je voulais quand même
regardé
j'ai envie d'en profiter c'est bon pour
les yeux
[Musique]
madagascar
le prince des lémuriens le roi des
lémuriens dire un comportement humain
c'est assez hallucinant tu as un petit
pizy fait pas trop le malin donc là
où j'ai très peur tenu les rênes déjà
faut pas que tu montres que tu shepherd
a évincé du monde que tu as peur au
chômage il va le franchir non je vais
tomber oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh
c'est king kong là mais j'ai jamais vu
ça de ma vie me fous 3 75 g de sucre en
poudre ou sucre semoule alors je prends
un petit peu êtes non mince on vous fait
quoi là entre noah je pense que j'avais
degrés si je mets trois
[Musique]
oui on vous confirme en fait pour poser
les ingrédients vincent on les met dans
un bol en
attente à quai le règlement est bien
fait pour elle oui 00 elle gagne non
mais un côté dolce vita s'est détendu ya
pas d'argent je veux tu vois c'est relax
quoi lui une bonne ambiance c'est con
alors on est à ça quand même tous ennuyé
un moi je moi j'aime bien quand on est
un peu plus tendue sambé moment alors
maintenant alors vous savez quoi la
classe de la classe c'est de n'avoir
trouvé aucune parole depuis le début et
de chaume et 20000 à oui et non parce
que si vous faites encore 0 ça ne serait
pas une surprise
sur 1500 vous devez déduire le poids du
bol à l'eau il ya quelqu'un oui mais
voilà bon allez faire là bas une
soustraction tout simplement
faux calculs tous
bah oui c'est ça aussi le dîner presque
parfait c'est se mettre à l'épreuve mais
comment j'ai pu faire ça moi quand ça me
plait pas quand j'ai un doute j'en ai
pas je recommence allez hop c'est pour
ça que j'avais 4 ans fort que je rigole
exact c'est votre premier enfant c'est
mon premier enfant et ben oui il
explique que si aussi un petit peu ne
regardez la jupe c'est normal alors
comment vous l'avez fait
j'ai joué de mon corps est assez ça il y
avait des gens chez moi j'étais avec un
truc année un arc et des flèches et jean
mais il y avait des gens très important
non genres théâtraux y avait même des
politiques mais ma mère et je leur tirer
des flèches dans luc non je vous le jure
c'est assez ya mon ami que j'aime
d'ailleurs il faut que je rappelle
franck dubosc était là et il dit il n'y
a que chez hanouna